US bases overseas do not ensure national
security hi I'm Nick Gillespie with
reason TV and today we are talking with
David vine is the author most recently a
base nation and he's an associate
professor of anthropology at American
University in Washington DC his writing
has appeared in The New York Times The
Washington Post The Guardian Mother
Jones The Chronicle of Higher Education
and many other publications David thanks
for talking to us thank you bass nation
talks about the US military footprint
around the world how many bases do we
have and how many countries are we in
right now we have on the order of 800 US
military bases outside the 50 states and
washington DC anything from city-sized
bases in Japan or Germany that have been
there since the end of World War two
tens of thousands of troops family
members shopping hospitals etc all the
way to put our frequently called lily
pad bases they might have just a few
hundred military personnel no family is
none of the amenities you might see if
the larger bases right now we're in 80
countries the end of the Cold War there
were US bases in 40 countries and
territories so we were in more countries
now than at the end of the Cold War
where is the American overseas presence
mostly stationed a lot of it is still
focused in Europe and East Asia where
it's been since World War two Germany
Japan South Korea Italy are the big ones
but there's been a growing constellation
of bases in and around the Middle East
since 1980s and that's the the other
major development we are spending around
150 billion dollars a year to maintain
bases and troops overseas how big a
chunk of money is 150 billion dollars
it's huge it's larger than the budget of
any government agency except the
Department of Defense itself and dwarfs
the the budget of the State Department
for example and this is just us bases
and troops overseas the Pentagon is
seeking to build up a network of bases
in Africa the Middle East Asia to help
combat Isis is the current enemy du jour
military officials say that the network
would be a hub for special ops and
intelligence operations conducting
counterterrorism missions
for the foreseeable future given the
fear of Isis metastasizing and other
terrorist groups like that doesn't the
US need to show its presence in places
like Africa the Middle East in order to
show you know what we're not retreating
from the world what what is wrong with
that argument well first of all the
military has been building up its
presence in places like Africa and
Southeast Asia and of course the Middle
East since nine eleven and and that
presence is again been all too often
counterproductive in Africa in
particular the Africa commands track
record is quite poor including by the
Pentagon's own assessment so how is it
pour in I mean are they not operating
the basis properly often they again the
presence of a US base of US troops gives
insurgents something to rally around and
a recruiting tool you also see in Africa
the Africa commands humanitarian track
record has been has been a poor to say
the least and again this is the the
Pentagon zones inspection and inspector
general came to this conclusion so to to
expand the us-based presence in Africa
the Middle East and elsewhere would only
be to double down on a strategy that
that has not worked that in fact helped
give rise to Isis to cut to the chase do
military bases overseas do they enhance
American national security US bases
overseas do not ensure national security
and in fact we can national security in
a range of ways from the money being
spent on these bases that could be used
to defend the United States in more
effective ways we could be using it as
well to ensure that that Americans are
secure in a variety of other ways their
their health care their education we
could give them the money back and I
could spend it the other way that these
bases are importantly undermining US
national security is that especially in
the Middle East they've actually spawned
radicalization they've led and research
has shown this they've led to increased
al-qaeda
the presence of US bases and troops we
need only look at Osama bin Laden's
professed motivation for the attacks of
911 explain the reasons to take that
seriously because it is interesting when
you know when that came up people were
like well you know you can't trust him
he just destroyed the world trade center
but what why do we think that that's
true then first of all he was talking
about it long before the attacks
themselves secondly research has shown
that put some bin Laden the side that
the presence of US bases has led to
increased al-qaeda recruitment so I
think there are a range of reasons and
we need only look at Iraq and
Afghanistan to see how how US bases have
become actually convenient targets we
can also look at the attacks in Saudi
Arabia for example and attacks going at
back to the 1980s in fact in Germany
during the Cold War it would it would be
more convincing right to say that you
know basis in western Germany in west
germany were there because we needed a
we both wanted a tripwire as well as a
forward possible unit to deal with any
kind of invasion threat but that no
longer there's no reason to believe that
say our troops in Saudi Arabia are
actually making Saudi Arabia more secure
for Saudi Arabians I think that's
exactly right that in the Cold War there
was a legitimate argument that basis
played a defensive role but I think in
the post-cold war era what we've seen is
that basis have largely made it all too
easy to go to war so when did the u.s.
begin building these bases and what was
the reason the vast majority of the
bases grew up during World War two the
US has had some bases overseas since the
19th century Guantanamo Bay of course
the most prominent Guam would be another
and it's important to note that the US
has said extraterritorial basis since
the 19th century they played a key role
in the conquest of the west but the the
base infrastructure we see today grows
up during the Lord Zhu beginning with
the destroyer stories four bases deal
that that FDR signs of getting access to
British bases and British colonies
around the world and then in exchange
for giving them
ships world war one era ships exactly
and this is before the US has entered
the war when the u.s. enters the war
military basically aims to create as
many bases as possible in as many places
as possible worldwide and we and it's by
the end of World War two you've written
that the u.s. had built over 2,000 bases
in just five years does that give rise
or plausibly to is it a new form of
colonialism it's quite clear that these
bases are a major facet of us global
power in the post-war era and this is
new and it's new for any power or Empire
or nation and world history to have
overseas bases so central to the
exercise of power so central to waging
or wielding influence around the world
and putting pressure on another nations
not just militarily but but to use the
military base as a way to get its way
economically politically and otherwise
is it partly the argument that well if
we didn't have them there you know it
would be the Russians or it would be the
Chinese or it would be whoever that is
sometimes the argument the other I think
the central argument has been since the
end of World War two that the United
States must have as many bases as
possible outside its territory and
company by hundreds of thousands of
troops to ensure US national security
the idea at beginning of the Cold War
was to put us bases and troops as close
as possible to the enemy the Soviet
Union and this was absolutely necessary
to ensure US national security basically
that assumption has gone unquestioned
especially in the post-cold war era when
the Soviet Union no longer exists and
yet the infrastructure bases and troops
has remained so in no way the rationale
for it is gone but the reality of it
still exists a scholars congressional
investigation back in the late 1960s
early 1970s showed that once a base is
established it becomes very difficult to
shut down it takes on a life of its own
part of a base is also it is an economic
reality and in a local place and a lot
of people will talk about say in Japan
and that one of the reasons why Japan
was able to rebuild or was able to
flourish economically is because the US
by having such massive presence there
and also the fact that we you know
denied Japan the right to rearm for a
long time that they don't have to spend
money on defense we're shouldering that
burden they can spend more money on
their local needs as well as their their
economy is that the case does the
presence of a US military base actually
have a positive economic influence on
the area that it's in Jessamine
definitely has a positive economic
interest for some people I think that's
the key we are spending around 150
billion dollars a year by my calculation
to maintain bases and troops overseas
that money has to go somewhere a lot of
it goes to US military contractors that
build and maintain the bases but a lot
also goes into the Japanese economy to
Japanese contractors Japanese base
employees they're supplying the food
there you know cleaning the barracks or
keeping the grounds or whatever that's
exactly right but I think what we see is
that that these sorts of investments do
not create thriving economies Okinawa is
a prime example the US has occupied
Okinawa since the end of World War two
around twenty-five percent of the island
is occupied by US military bases and the
okinawa is the poorest prefecture in all
of japan this is not created a thriving
economy so it's kind of I mean it's like
a Potemkin economy where it's there but
it's kind of like a giant sports stadium
or something where there's not actually
real economic activity going on yeah if
you think about it bases are large
swaths of territory taken up by the
military much of it unused or used for
training and used sporadically where
nothing is produced and this was not a
democrat or republican issue that's
exactly right in the underlying foreign
policy assumption that we must have
these bases overseas that they're
absolutely essential to US national
security has been a bipartisan agreement
we need to engage diplomatically engage
politically find other forms of
engagement and fundamentally reshape
u.s. foreign policy
away from the military dominated
military base dominated foreign policy
that we've seen in that has been so
counterproductive we have been talking
with David vine he's the author of bass
nation and he's an associate professor
of anthropology at American University
for a reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie